la sortie de crise en tunisie au coeur
des échanges entre ryad et anthony
blinken alors que tunis ce peine à
convaincre ses bailleurs de fonds le
chef de l'état a réaffirmé lors de son
entretien téléphonique avec le chef de
la diplomatie américaine sa volonté de
réformer conditions plus que nécessaire
à une reprise des négociations avec les
institutions financières internationales
le point avec notre correspondant à
tunis ben hassen chébili
blinken sayed un entretien aux allures
de mise au point dans un communiqué
publié hier relatifs à la conversation
téléphonique de samedi entre les deux
hommes le palais de carthage a réaffirmé
les engagements du président de la
république parmi eux accéléré la mise en
place des réformes attendues par les
institutions internationales en vue de
sortir le pays de la crise économique et
qu'il traverse skies a elle annoncé sa
volonté de passer de la situation
exceptionnelle actuelle un retour à la
normale en appelant les partenaires
nationaux et internationaux à davantage
prendre en compte les crises économiques
et sociales qui gangrène le pays de son
côté blinken a rappelé que les
attributions dead dépendront de la
capacité de tunis à mettre en place
rapidement les réformes nécessaires tout
en réitérant le soutien permanent des
états unis à la tunisie notamment auprès
des institutions financières
internationales
au pied du mur sayyed a justifié les
raisons de son coup de force et le
recours de l'article 81 la constitution
nécessité absolue selon lui au vu des
conflits partisans et la corruption
endémique et qui gangrène le parlement
tunisien il a ajouté que la levée de
l'immunité des parlementaires avaient
permis certaines poursuites judiciaires
et coûté la constitution n'a pas été
suspendue il a été procédé uniquement au
gel des membres de l'assemblée
parlementaire jusqu'à la fin du péril
auquel est exposé le pays certains
députés faisait l'objet de poursuites
judiciaires depuis 2018 alors que
d'autres se revendique victimes alors
qu'ils sont les premiers responsables de
la détérioration de la situation en
tunisie le diplomate américain a
également rappelé la nécessité du
respect des droits de l'homme et des
libertés référence aux allégations
portées par certains membres de
l'opposition de la société civile
notamment en termes de restriction du
droit à manifester des accusations
démenties par le chef de l'état qui a
rappelé que la liberté de manifester
avec et garantit ces derniers mois
contrairement aux informations propagées
et depuis la crise politique du 25
juillet dernier thijs ayed s'est arrogé
la quasi totalité des pouvoirs en
suspendant le parlement et en limogeant
le premier ministre une initiative que
certains de ces opposants ont qualifié
de coup d'état et qui selon eux aurait
remis en question les acquis
démocratiques de la révolution du jasmin
de 2011